house i'm looking at you sir are you
gonna give me a zebra or a horse i don't
know let's check it out on this house md
medical review
what are you kidding me tub of goo
there's gotta be over six bills you
ain't gonna lift it with a couple of
blankets no this is totally einstein
yeah just just roll him off
but he's already dead ain't like he's
gonna feel it this is actually a
situation that some of my paramedic
friends discussed with me about
legitimately having trouble getting
humans outside of their homes into the
ambulance and into the er there's even
been times that i've heard them talk
about injuring themselves bringing
patients out of their homes because they
were perhaps overweight or obese or
perhaps their environment wasn't safe
all right one two
come on man
me you're the killer boss kid wasn't me
oh
whoa it wasn't me either
don't look at
me is the patient alive did no one check
for a pulse trust me skin's cold pupils
are fixed and dilated he's not breathing
he's got a pulse he's not dead if he has
a pulse 46 year old guy in a coma
doesn't appear to be anything wrong with
him except for the fact that he weighs
over 600 pounds who says that who who
talks about a patient's weight like that
and says there's probably nothing wrong
do you know that do you know his history
he can't even give you his full history
there's no way you could have results
this quickly like at least get an
echocardiogram blood sugar's normal
cholesterol is lower than mine toxic
screen's clean no sign of trauma sure
there wasn't a mix up with the lab three
times i'm glad that they rechecked
because if a clinical picture meaning
what a patient looks like behaves like
or symptoms are like don't match the
labs you should be rechecking those labs
too many times i've had that happen
recheck the labs and find out they're
completely normal or the other way
completely abnormal so i always like to
keep laboratory error in the back of my
mind or in the front of my mind the
forefront of my mind my mind there's
nothing abnormal in the eeg or the
neurological exam who gets an eg when a
patient just rolls in it's too soon you
should get a cat scan see what the lungs
are like get an echo see what the
anatomy of the heart is like you should
see what the digestive system is like
with a cat scan when a patient comes in
and you don't know what's going on you
have to throw all the tests at the
patient in order to understand what's
going on you need to check for substance
abuse you need to check for toxic
metabolites complete metabolic panel the
complete blood count look at all these
values and not just jump to conclusions
i mean like doing an eeg seems like the
50th step and they've skipped over 1
through 49. improperly prepared puffer
fish can have toxins that could cause a
coma and might not show up on the talk
screen and if it was a puffer fish he'd
be dead in six to eight hours time so
he's been in a coma at least 24. how do
people know this fact about puffer fish
come on foreman you didn't know that you
googled it he googled it this is
ridiculous a person shouldn't be able to
eat themselves into oblivion and then
just expect everyone to pull out the
stops to fix everything what are we
supposed to do refuse treatment to
anyone who's obese come on give me a
break disguise on my face
he's not even morbidly obese he's
suicidal people who attempt suicide get
treated when you have non-compliant
diabetic stone wait non-compliant
diabetics do get treated i don't know
why he said that and patients who
are addicted to food or perhaps have
an emotional issue that is causing them
to overeat and become 600 pounds or
perhaps have a medical condition that's
causing them to gain this much weight
shouldn't be judged like you can't be a
doctor and be this judgy and be
successful as a clinician you should do
an lp with neurosyphilis it's not
syphilis how do you know whatever he has
is connected to his gut now what's below
it mra his brain look for clots
she said that the blood was drawn three
times
in that time they couldn't check for
syphilis
one two three
not gonna lie this is a true challenge
for hospital and hospital systems when
patients can't fit in the equipment
that's why we are trying to create newer
equipment that is more uh capable in
handling patients of all different sizes
and shapes no bleeds clots influx i
don't see any edema either so what do we
do now an lp even if it's not an std a
fever boys towards some sort of
infection i'm not sure we can do an lp
on a guy his size did they get a chest
x-ray like if you at least had a chest
x-ray you could do that portable you
could do it right in the bed you could
see if that there was a lung infection
you could rule that out check the urine
see if there's a urinary tract infection
with the pylonephritis going up to the
kidneys like why aren't they talking
about the most common things this show
is all about zebras not horses remember
that saying when you hear hoof beats
think horses not zebras doesn't mean you
forget the zebras just means you think
the horse is first calm down man calm
down get him out already i'm trying
we still have no idea why he was in the
coma to begin with or why he woke up
what if it is hormones acute adrenal
insufficiency could cause a temporary
coma it can and also a thyroid storm can
cause a coma although a thyroid storm
would probably come with a rapid heart
rate also not weight gain if you have a
hyperactive thyroid although if you have
an underactive thyroid followed by
thyroid storm which can happen because
the thyroid even in like certain uh
conditions like hashimoto's and graves
disease sometimes it flips on and off
between hyper and hypothyroid it's not
always so clearly defined especially in
the beginning of the onset of disease to
later stages of disease we should do a
full std panel and check his genitals
for shankers well first of all you
should have checked him for shankers
beforehand and you should have done a
full sed panel beforehand it's like the
cheapest test you can do if you're
talking about all these mris that you're
breaking costing millions of dollars the
300 std panel would have been worth it
don't you think are you having any
problems with your vision no i have
nystagmus i've had it since birth i'm
fine you're not fine you're in a coma
for two days there's something wrong
with you was something wrong with me now
i'm better now i'd like to go home the
patient can always leave like if he can
think about the consequences if the
patient can verbalize those consequences
and it's safe for them to leave in that
sense they can choose to leave they will
leave against medical advice which is an
ama but it's within their rights it's
patient autonomy wait let us take you
all the way outside i'm fine
uh it
doesn't matter it's hospital rules oh
screw the rules i've been on my back for
four days i need the exercise right
george come on let us just take you to
the taxi don't worry i may not be able
to climb everest but i can walk
[Music]
first of all if a patient has not gotten
up since he's been admitted to the
hospital would get a pt evaluation to
see if he's capable of walking on his
own and if he's not he cannot safely go
home alone he would at least need to go
to a subacute rehab stay where he could
learn how to walk on his own and take
care of himself cause if a patient can't
get up and walk you're essentially
setting them up for failure by sending
them home
[Music]
i think we should focus on the coma and
the fever we have a rather large piece
of tempered glass that begs to differ i
just mean it's not connected how could
you possibly know because i did it
i didn't think he should be discharged
so i
gave him three grams of benaton
what hospital is this she drugged the
patient so he wouldn't leave oh my god
don't poison your patients even if you
think it's right for them because you
are not god
what would happen to her
medical license lost we'll do it in
order they find out
medical review committee medical board
suspension followed by medical board
revaluation followed by loss of medical
license either temporarily or forever
depending on how angry the patient is
prior situations etc etc
lawyer up it can't be chagas he's never
been outside the country his stomach has
the food we eat no longer comes from
america's heartland it comes from south
america's deforested jungle land where
lettuce now grows and let his pickers
now poop get a sample of his csf how are
you gonna get a sample of this
cerebrospinal fluid that's gonna be
tough you wanna drill a hole in my head
it's gotta be something other than a
parasite i buy my produce it's the best
market in town and i always wash it
leafy vegetables can set contaminated
water through the roots right into the
plant i've never heard this
this sounds far-fetched but
i hope they research this
please tell me this is a neurosurgeon
doing this not like foreman
it's forming oh my god these they're all
neurosurgeons infectious disease
specialists family medicine doctors
cardiologists they run mri machines
oh cramp what what'd you do nothing
what's wrong i can't
i can't see vision's blurry or you've
lost i didn't lose it you took it from
george calm down i can't speak this is
actually why patients are kept awake
during some neural procedures because in
case you do touch something you want to
know right away so that you don't
continue doing damage in that area
blindness plus coma says diabetes no
blood sugar urine dipstick and
hemoglobin a1c are normal we're normal
when you test it spin it out of a coma
whatever's going on is waxing and waning
that's not true because the hemoglobin
a1c gives you an average of the blood
sugars over the last three months so it
doesn't mean it was normal today it
could be different tomorrow it still
will give you the average of the last
three months so i don't agree with house
here i am not diabetic the sooner you
drink this the sooner i get to go waste
my time with something else
get the hell off of me no dessert till
you finish your dinner
such a classic house situation where
he's just losing his mind fighting a
patient
go
wait his liver is failing now he's
jaundiced what's happening get x-rays of
his hands tell him that lung cancer is
in no way connected to obesity uh you
don't think he'll realize we're lying
you're not
lung cancer's got nothing to do with
makes about him having lung cancer he
didn't notice his fingers
i noticed they were fat you should have
pissed them off he would have grabbed
you and you would have felt the bones
they're not just fat
they're clubbed
[Music]
this is the first x-ray they're getting
are you joking he was in a coma in the
icu and they're just getting an x-ray
now
oh they're getting an x-ray of his hand
i thought this is the first chest x-ray
they're getting your tests were positive
you have a small cell lung carcinoma
it caused a perineoplastic neurologic
syndrome perineoplastic basically means
that as a result of having this tumor it
secreted hormones that have altered the
way that his body behaves it's
inoperable but there are radiation
treatments available
[Music]
they might give you a few more months
i never smoked not all lung cancer cases
are caused by smoking some are caused by
asbestos
i would ask if he had any questions at
that point i mean you're just delivering
a life-changing diagnosis you spend 10
seconds and you leave i think that's
kind of cold
check out the harsh reality of being 800
plus pounds here click it check it out
as always stay happy and healthy